je suis pas fait pour être en couple
de grand love là avec un escalier en
colimaçon là pour être bien
après les études tout ça on n'a jamais
reparlé pourquoi on partirait pas
maintenant camionnette sur les routes
même pas
c'est ça qui vous faut
carrément le truc de Hollandais là
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire comme
vous montrerez
ce que c'est j'ai déjà travaillé je sais
ce que c'est aussi et c'est pas ce que
je veux
c'est ça le voyage c'est ça on va oser
plein de trucs on va oser
c'est vraiment content ça fait des
années que je suis pas sorti comme ça
je connais pas ce qui sera super pour
moi c'est que je puisse faire un petit
bout de chemin avec vous le temps de
savoir
tu comprends